democrats control two branches of
government and are attempting to control
the third
by packing the supreme court with
liberal justices on top of that
the fourth estate the media continues to
look the other way
and now my next guest says she is fed up
with the politics of it all
joining me now with her first fox news
appearance
is one of my heroes rose mcgowan former
actress
best-selling author change maker and one
of time magazine's
persons of the year may i say rose that
you are also
my person of the year if not for several
years having been in several years i
have no doubt moving forward
thank you so much for joining us tonight
i really appreciate it
thank you so much for having me tammy
you know this is your you
are known by many people based on how
the media has chosen to portray you
uh it's in snippets it's in blocks we
know that your life has been unique
you've had important experiences that
you've taken action on
but not a lot of people have heard
directly from you about why that's
important
what you're doing now you're an
entrepreneur you're a businesswoman
we're going to talk about that soon
but talk to everyone here who may for
the first time may be seeing you
directly after hearing your name for so
long having done such a great job
in standing up for your rights uh your
dignity and the dignity of women
everywhere
uh why did you do that and what is it
meant to the quality of your life and
why is it so important for everyone to
understand
well as some of you know some of you
don't know if you've heard my name
or read anything on me in the media i
grew up in a cult
and it was a very famous cult called
children of god
and it gave me a power it gave me the
ability to see
the control and the propaganda machine
especially in the us for what it is and
how it harms people
and how the left can harm people just as
much
uh as the right if they go very very
deep into it
and ignore all other aspects of kind of
reality in a way
and and that you're serving a master
that might not be serving you and i
always say i come in peace
i am not here to make people feel bad
about their political choices but i am
here to say
that you might be in a cult too if you
don't know the signs and and i do
believe democrats most especially
are in a deep cult that they really
don't
uh and know about and aren't really
aware of and
i leave the republicans alone more
because i do
respect people more that are like this
is what we are
this is what we're about this is what
we're against
whereas i find that the democrats are
really
pretty much almost against all the same
things
they're against um changing the world
for the better and
and they're for keeping a system in
place
that is for so few people and benefits
so few
but they masquerade as the as the
helpers we would do this
the world would be perfect if only those
republicans would get out of the way
well okay
you've got control so now what what are
you going to do to make the world better
you see this is it comes down to an
issue of betrayal really because neither
one of us are republicans
right i mean we we are the women that
were supposed to be the beneficiaries
of all of these programs and promises of
the democrats
and here we are in a world where
republicans have been demonized
and yet you know i identify as a
conservative
it does irritate certain people but it
really is about freedom it's about
personal freedom about living lives that
best suit us
and that's what you're doing as well uh
when it comes to the
the choices look a great actress you're
a writer uh
you are a businesswoman you have a new
beloved you actually have
time for a relationship uh and you
you're happy you're becoming at least
happier uh considering the nature of
what you experienced
from hollywood is that something you
regularly struggle with when it comes to
being yourself and embracing what who it
is you're becoming
and what's important about that
i'm embracing in my life right now
really just almost healing in a way not
just for me but for so many others you
know
during the metoo media period it was
just triggers for
so many women and men alike you know
everybody really and it was a painful
period for very many people
as as it was for me sure you know and
and my
persecution um
an awakening from being a democrat was
so much
about what i do and what i say now
and so much about realizing
how hardcore of a cult it is you know
what's interesting
so the ability is to women and the
people it says it's going to help
then why haven't they achieved anything
well see that's it and then we're also
tied to this idea of what could happen
afraid of what we would say or not
say but without being able to be true to
ourselves even after the feminist
movement
still trying to conform and that's kind
of the
the rub here is this this art this
expectation
that a woman like you is better off if
you conform
but that is the opposite of your
creativity it's the opposite of what
would
fuel uh what makes uh the world
interesting to you
for the for the bit of time that we have
left what advice would you give
the young women listening of course but
it also goes to whatever age we are
with what you've gone through and and
how each day
takes something new you've got to adapt
all the time
what advice in this new age as we're
trying to come together and unite on the
things that that bring us together
what would you say to every woman
watching
i would say to every woman and man or
any you know
anybody watching that film does come out
and your personal freedom comes at the
price of you
realizing how you're being controlled
and where it's coming from and separate
i would make a list
your belief system and figure out what
your belief system
what part of it is organic to you and
what part has been implanted either by
hollywood or
the media or or your leaders
what part of it is it's truly yours
what's organic to you
and see what's the polyester and pull it
out of your fabric we have to examine
what we believe and why i'm going to get
a lot of hate
for being on fox news that's just a fact
i've gotten people you know on the left
yelling at me like you go up against
biden
um you go up against the clintons you go
up i'm like yes but all of these people
had
uh the clintons um have had a direct
hand in helping
one of my perpetrators who was one of
the most powerful democratic donors
there was
and also their entree into the hollywood
world and i've been persecuted by them
and i find that i had to even look
through what had been implanted in me
so i would say look at your own belief
systems and get free
you can still believe in whatever party
you want to believe in
but not to the limit where it makes it
so you cannot have a human conversation
with every other person and it doesn't
mean
that your even your politics change it
it means that you become more free
within that framework
rose i know that as people were to
follow you on social media they'll get
an example of how to do this where where
can people find your work these days
uh at rose mcgowan on twitter where i am
shadow band and suppressed
at instagram rose mcgowan uh instagram's
kind of my softer side
twitter i go hard but you know they
suppress me and so does
facebook and everybody else it's it's
just because i go up against the sacred
cows
that's not supposed to go up against the
new york times you're not supposed to go
up against the propagandists that's
right and i
think if someone is evil they're evil
and they should call them out whether
it's right or left
or somewhere in the middle because they
are the ones keeping us apart the
propaganda
machine in conjunction with whatever
party
is determined to have control over our
freedom and they say
america is the land of the free well we
have to fight for it
i'm not conservative in my beliefs i
believe in
different personal freedoms and maybe
people watching this but i can still be
your friend
i can still be your ally and i can still
want the best for you
brava this is this is the heroism that i
was talking about
it's a it's beautiful thank you rose
thank you so much for coming on i
appreciate it
and uh we'll talk soon thank you very
much for joining us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else